for 46 years they have been coming to
this Plaza in front of the presidential
Palace to demand to know the whereabouts
of their missing
children Argentina back then was ruled
by a brutal military dictatorship that
tortured disappeared and killed
thousands of center-left political
opponents but this women never gave
up Candela Fernandez says the election
of far-right candidate Javier M has
steered fears among human rights
activist that freedom of speech and
political activism in the country might
soon be at risk
again there is fear about what will
happen in a country with a government
with an agenda like mes it also
generates the uncertainty that we will
have to
resist aier M has promised to reform the
Argentine State and Implement austerity
measures that will reduce government
spending people here fear that this will
impoverish the population and that this
will lead to Violent protests on the
streets Javier m is now getting his
cabinet ready ahead of his inauguration
on December 10th he says he's also
planning a trip to Israel to show his
support to prime minister Benyamin
Netanyahu for Argentina his victory is a
radical shift to the right mle has
questioned a decade long consensus on
the atrocities committed by the
dictatorship Argentina has tried and
detained at least one ,000 members of
the security forces involved in human
rights
abuses the new vice president has
defended those who committed a genocide
they compare what leftwing gorillas did
with the abuses committed by the state
it was State terrorism and it is not the
same Argentina is preparing for the
beginning of a new era most people are
desperate for economic stability but
others fear there may be a steep price
to pay
Al
bu make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer